Intro name: 'Child Protective Services Theme' by Nero ASIN BAYRAKLARI TURKIYE
*quack*
What's in here?
A bucket!
*old door moving*
Yes of course I have the same bucket.
*footsteps*
*knock x1*
*knock x2*
*knock x3*
Hello?
HUAH
JAVLA FITTA! (Fucking Pussy)
Oh!
Ayyy!
Alright that's cool, I'm just gonna go... *Gasp*
BATTERIES! WHEN THE MORNINGS GONE AND YOU CAN'T GO... *QUIET LAUGH*
How're you doing there, buddy?
Dude you look good, honestly like *slap slap*
*quack*
*Evil laugh*
Oh god.
Who's laughing?
Fuck me , uh.
I'm a bunny
Alright?
You can't hurt a bunny
No one would ever hurt a bunny, alright?
A voice: Jessica? PewDiePie: Oh JA - WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?!
Oh!
*Sinister Laughter*
Get me the fuck outta here, I'm running out of batteries!
Fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck
OH! WH-STOP DOING THE SHADOW THING, YOU'RE NOT EVEN A REAL LOCKER!
Oh god, okay, alright, that's cool, I don't care, WHATEVER, FUCK YOU!
*quack*
Thanks for watching! Outro name :Child Protective Services theme by Nero